hey so I go to the article my comments
not there yeah if we're talking about me
- we wouldn't want the woman who was
actually physically raped in there I
don't think you're gonna make the cut
glad to have our next guest on the
program this is actually she's a return
guest we've had a run before a long time
ago actually believe during the 2016
campaign you can go you can go get her
book now wherever books are sold
you'd better put some ice on that the
author and our website of course and I
ruined I ruined the the prestige but
it's Juanita Broderick calm miss
Broderick thanks for being here well I
appreciate coming on the show and
especially at this time right now your
story is as relevant as ever and I know
it's a tough story to tell I thought you
write about this in your book for those
who maybe aren't super familiar you know
some some new viewers can you kind of
explain to them how you came to the the
public spotlight with what's the Clinton
issue I don't want to speak for you
because you know I have a man and
hashtag men don't know anything Bill
Clinton's gubernatorial campaign I was a
nursing home owner I was a registered
nurse but someone asked me to volunteer
so I thought well this would be good
I've never been involved in politics and
I did this for absolutely a month when I
had a call from the campaign office and
said Bill Clinton was going to be in the
area and could he come by and visit at
my nursing home I'm so excited I mean
the whole staff the families the
residents we were all excited right and
then that pictured this on the front of
my book was from the local newspaper and
after the photo op Bill Clinton comes
over to me and starts talking and and
he's so charismatic then you know he
never loses eye contact with you when
he's talking to you yeah it's actually a
skill though he's able to make it seem
like he's making eye contact while
simultaneously staring at your breasts
that's a skill of his but yes well okay
so apologies but continue yeah with the
time
here well what a perfect opportunity
nursing homes in Arkansas were
struggling the per diem rate was so low
and we couldn't adequately feel for
instance so I just offered this
information to him and he looked at me
and you thought he said are you ever in
Little Rock and I said yes I'll be there
in three weeks and he said well why
don't you call my office and let's get
together and talk about this I couldn't
believe it I was so excited and I worked
for two or three days on eating graphs
and everything and what the cost was and
what we were being reimbursed so then
the day comes in April the 24th 1978 my
nurse and I Drive down to Little Rock
the next morning we get up and we call
Bill Clinton's office and the young lady
answers and tells me that he's not there
to give me a number to call I call the
number he answers the phone I tell him
that we have an hour for a lunch break
could I please come over and meeting
this office at noon and bringing the
information and of course it's
long-drawn saying well I'm not gonna be
there today why don't I just come to
your hotel now this was eight o'clock in
the morning so his office became your
hotel very quickly
that's pretty smooth pretty smooth
operation there I've never heard of a
not well actually that's not sure I have
heard of offices being in hotel rooms
that's notably you know when Kevin
Spacey's producing a new picture
continue you go on to the meeting and
I'll be there shortly after I leave the
coffee shop we plan to lead to meet in
the coffee shop downstairs when he gets
to the hotel he calls my room and he
says there's so many people down here
and there's reporters he said can we
just talk about this and have coffee in
your room I didn't really think anything
about it I know I must have been leery
because I've never
alone in a hotel room with a man I
didn't know I mean really yeah so but he
was the Attorney General so I said sure
an hour to coffee to the room and he
comes up and the first thing when I
opened the door there he stands in the
hall right just him but I didn't look at
I don't know who else was sweeping we
sunglasses on we're talking to dim-lit
Holloway with sunglasses that should
have been a tip-off that like I said you
could have thought it was a style thing
people wearing sunglasses back then it's
just she thought it was the sunglasses
thing I get it yeah just absolutely
pathetic so he comes in and we all know
the story that he finally he asked me to
come over to his side of the table while
I was pouring the coffee and he wanted
to he pointed to a little building that
was down on the Arkansas River you could
see it from my window and he said to me
I want to show you this I should never
have walked around that time but anyway
things really went south I mean they it
was horrible right into scream when he
grabbed me and tried to kiss me and when
he forced me on the bed and start
tearing at my clothes I began to scream
again well this time whenever I did he
would bite my upper lip and it was I
just never forget how painful that was
yeah and then after the right I was
devastated I set up on the side of the
bed and I was crying and he stays gets
out and he's straightening himself and
he just sort of looks at me real girl
wildered and he says don't worry I'm
sterile I had mumps when I was a child
my god man you just raped me and that's
what you had to say and then he just
looked at me again put on his sunglasses
calmly walk to the door and motion to my
mouth which was swollen three times the
normal size all of this just turned me
inside out and bleeding and he says you
better put some ice on that and walks
out
and that's the title of your book where
people can check it out at Juanita
Broderick calm I want to make sure one
thing here because obviously the reason
we're having you on is is because of
right now the hashtag me to movement and
we see what's been going on with with
Kavanagh you're saying I know that
people will say these are allegations we
have to we have to address that but I do
think there's a big difference in I
think no one would deny this the
treatment of your allegations from the
meeting before we get to the details
that you've had which have not been
actually corroborated from stories
thirty years ago the treatment of you
coming forward against Bill Clinton
versus every single woman who comes
forward today with Kavanagh have you
seen that contrast absolutely no the
woman that found me right she would not
have Joseph well let me ask you this
when did this event happen was built
with Bill Clinton in yourself April the
25th 1978 at 8:30 in the morning it and
where did it occur the hotel was called
the Camelot I don't know what it's
called right now
now pivotal for people listening those
are more details that have come forward
in any accusation against Cavanaugh and
we'll get to more but it's important
that people note it's not even close
some people say you're just going to it
for Ted no no we're not playing the same
game here details where when with
specificity and I appreciate that miss
Broderick they've provided none but I
remember what really really bothered me
the first time you're on the show and I
think we talked about it was when I I
looked into it a little bit more you
actually agreed to do an interview if
I'm not mistaken with with someone NBC
was at leat Alisa Meyers somewhere in
the late 90s and this was I think was it
was it the day after Bill Clinton was
impeached
it was just a few days now I have been
talking with Lisa Myers for over a year
trying to come forward and I refused
completely yes and and she sat on the
story for over a month yeah no he didn't
yes she begged them to do this and she
said she called me one day because they
they filmed on January the 20th 1999 and
it didn't get on the TV I mean it wasn't
aired until I think February 26 and more
than that right I think she called me
one day because I was upset this was
supposed to be aired during the
impeachment that's the only reason I
went on it I thought this can stop this
man and they wait till after the
impeachment but before that I remember
her calling me one day and I said I
don't want to hear from ABC anymore and
she said well listen I've got good news
and bad news
she said the good news is you're
credible and the bad news is you're very
credible now what what do I do with that
I've never been interviewed before I
didn't understand all the specifics of
what that statement yet right yeah yeah
I understand it now very well also I
think it's important to note that the
response from from Clinton Bill Clinton
when he's asked about the issue he says
well you know what counsel as a my
lawyers has a statement and he just he
never flat-out denies it as opposed to
again Kavanagh saying these allegations
are completely false hey listen public
hearing as much information and
transparency as possible to clear my
name because as a woman who's been a
victim of rape and I don't want to go
through details and have you relive it
or if ever this goes any direction
you're uncomfortable please let us know
but I do think it's an important story
and I am interested as to your opinion
on you know what when when you're you're
you have the scales what tips the scales
and the balance of you know proof versus
right now believe all survivors really
believe all claims how do you view
what's happening now in in the court of
public opinion oh it's gonna be a
different situation regarding who the
person is and what their memory is if
there
they're not going to remember anything
right well I was completely awake having
coffee about to go to a seminar meeting
completely full dressed ready and I
think she had on a swimsuit it's I was
suspicious from the beginning before it
started to crumble there has to have
been someone she would have told if it
was that horrific right yeah that's
exactly what I would imagine I want to
be clear with your story you told
several people and I think was at Norma
Norma not Norma Jean oh that's a
danielson do is get normal with a normal
Rodgers she was my director of Nursing
and thank God I was there with her she's
the one that found me within 30 minutes
we got ice for my mouth and packed up
all her stuff she said when she came in
the door and but after she'd gone to get
the ice and we were sitting there while
I was crying and she was just about
trying to well I told her what happened
she said what do you want to do I said
oh please just take me off and people
will ask you know why didn't you press
charges then at that time no Clinton
they said why didn't you call the police
there was no DNA back then there was
nothing like that and Bill Clinton was
the police there's a pretty general of
my state he regulated my businesses he
could have closed me down on a whim
right yeah well I think I think that's
important to note as opposed to again
we're talking about Cavanaugh who who
isn't there yet you know and he's easy
he hasn't been appointed yet but it is
it is kind of crazy to me this is a guy
who still has reached high levels of
government that none of this had ever
come out obviously just from an outsider
perspective you're going real only
30-something years later thirty-five
years later and very different again
just mentioned normal Rogers there were
many people in your story it with your
but with this incident who corroborated
your story I don't want to say your
story because I don't want to make it
sound fictional I don't want to misspeak
there at all whereas in the case of of
Cavanaugh after Ford came forward all of
the friends declined to confirm the
story even when she was reaching out to
build
case it's a very very different sequence
of events which why which is why it
makes it so much more chilling to me
that I mean if people want to cover the
story if the media is interested in a
story if we're talking about really
helping victims survivors of sexual
assault why you weren't given more
opportunities to share your story it's
it's it's night and day
you know I'm flying to Washington DC in
the morning I'm going out there with Amy
Kremer and the women for Trump because
we want to stand with Brett Kavanaugh we
don't want these crazy pink cat wearing
ladies try to define what we women
really are here in 2018 so we're going
to be a part of that and I'm just so
happy that they asked me to go and
something else too that you bring up as
you bring up Kevin on some women now so
you and your friends supporting him
there's no pattern of behavior here I
think something it's very important is
you weren't the first woman to come
forward with Bill Clinton and you
weren't the last so it makes it even
more it's with kavanah there's no proof
of this at all in any instance not
saying it didn't happen I'm not saying
there's zero chance but again as a
pattern of behavior as a pattern of
character we don't see it with but come
on it's former President Bill Clinton
it's his calling card it might actually
be on his physical calling card for all
I know
so again it would seem to credible as
you said it so it where you have not
always acknowledged as credible behind
the scenes was at all was that always
the case or was it later on as the
evidence mounted and then they said we
got it let's just keep this quiet you
know I have no idea of his reputation
absolutely none until the years
progressed and I would hear about these
things
and when I was subpoenaed by Ken Starr
that was the first time I told the truth
the main reason that he subpoenaed least
because I had lied in the father John
suit I saw what had happened to the
other women and I'll be darned if I was
going to come forward and be persecuted
like that but he wanted to know was i
lying because they had threatened me or
paid me off
that's not no none of that happened I
could not
and to his obstruction of justice at all
so but they never discredited me I get
so upset so the reason the reason that
you lied at that point wasn't because of
any kind of bribery
it was just be just to protect your
reputation and because you thought
nothing good could come of it because
they were Teflon and to these other
women that were coming forward then I
ran nursing I don't know sir Holmes I
was a business woman I don't want him
disarmed to go away right after I
testified after I was deposed by Paula
Jones
I mean I was angry that someone could
try to pull me into their lawsuit for
their own personal gain I know Colin out
she's a fine young lady but I was angry
and I thought you're not going to do
this to me
but the reason they call me into it is
because two of our investigators showed
up on my front porch one day and
recorded me saying I'm not going to talk
about the most horrible at the end of my
life right hey that recording back to
Paula Jones attorneys and so naturally
I'm named Jane Doe number five in that
suit and I was saying I think that's
also important to note sort of this idea
of the the unwilling hero you you you
had a lot to lose right at this point
like you said a businesswoman you this
was something that you were not
interested in taking part whereas when
we talk about Ford Kavanagh she stands a
lot to gain as we see right now and
that's a contrast I think looking into
the evidence the specifics the
corroboration is from people who were
there we don't have that in any of these
other stories the pattern of behavior on
the the would-be assailant as well as
the motives behind the person coming
forward yours the reason I wanted have
you in the show is because I would say I
would say that nearly every case yours
is the inverse of Christine Ford or
whichever crimes I don't even know what
we're up to now someone said someone
said he showed us his is doneger at a
party is another thing you know I don't
know why we throw that under the same
pile as what you experienced an actual
rape with dr. Ford this course this is
on Twitter when people go after me and I
say dr. Ford's
our
Asians are 1% of what I went through you
cannot compare this in any way it makes
me angry that they can even say these
two things are comfortable right it is
odd to mean I've talked about this
obviously as an ignorant male but it
seems to be you know rapists or twisted
people right this is their twisted they
they're aroused by rape so it seems to
me that either a rapist if you're alone
in a room and the rapist is he either
rapes you unless you have a gun as a
woman
they don't stop mid rape and all right
get out of here you little rascal so the
only story that I think was generated
from Ford was he got so drunk that he
passed out and I got away that's
something to me that was very and I
would like you were insight on that as
someone who went through this ordeal it
seems very unlikely that someone who
lives for rape and this is what rapists
love they get a thrill out of it would
pass out because he's sleepy just beyond
me you know there's no way I could have
gotten away from Bill Clinton he's a
very large man and it's time I laid
maybe a hundred and ten pounds and you
know I'm gonna say that right now
Stephen I just get chills thinking about
how he held me down and when he did to
me you know it's and like I said I don't
wanna get into specifics I don't want
this to become a Barbara Walters so you
know salacious and everywhere I'm just
trying to make you but whatever you're
comfortable with he is especially he was
a large man back then was before he was
vegan he was still eat in the fast food
cheeseburgers so he probably had a few
extra pounds it's your fault and I still
had that mentality that it was my fault
for allowing him to come to the room and
this finally went away but it really
went away in 1991 when this I'm sorry
no that's fine go ahead wait when this
monster apologized to me I was down in
Iraq again with my nurse that it found
me that
and her sister both of alarians and
someone comes to the door and they say
miss Broderick is haunted in the hall so
I think and it's a emergency from home I
in a go out and they shortly after they
follow me and the man points down around
the corner to the elevator and so I walk
down there and look around and go around
the corner and as I do there stands Bill
Clinton and he's got his two arkansas
state policemen standing back behind him
and he comes over to me and he says I'm
so sorry for what I did
he said I'm a family man I'm a changed
man I'm just not that person anymore and
I you've got to realise been 13 years
since I've laid eyes on you right I just
sort of backed up and I started crying
and I thought you jerk
to myself and then I said you go to hell
and I turned him off to my friends and
they said what did he want and I said he
apologized two weeks before he announced
he was running for president but what
frightens me the most about that is that
he could reach out and touch me at that
time in my life and know where I was
right so even if it were meant to be a
sincere apology still be wildly
uncomfortable to the victim of sexual
assault
considering that this is the assault or
something I won't even think about yeah
reaching into your personal space and
two police officers behind them so if
you if you swatted in a law for you you
know you'd be in cuffs and you'd be in
the drunk tank for the evening yeah
that's uh that really is disconcerting
what we consider that you've you've been
through this and you you've really
written about it in detail so I
encourage people to go to your website
and check out your book again very very
different from what we're seeing today
what's what's been your take on this
whole you know hashtag me to movement it
started with Weinstein and Cosby which I
think everyone was on board with and I
don't know if you followed sort of the
norm ik Donald ordeal where they said
producers at The Tonight Show were
weeping his comments were you know it
started off as a hundred women can't or
a thousand women can't be lying then no
women can be lying and then
we have to believe all women all the
time which to me seems very reasonable
that's kind of my sentiment on this
movement but I'm curious as to where you
line up and how you've seen it evolve
anything to do with conservative women
and they especially want nothing to do
with the victims of Bill Clinton before
the ladies were named time Person of the
Year I got a call from Charlotte altar
Jonathan altars daughter who works for
time and she asked me to submit a
comment she said we'd really like for
you to give a comment in support of me
too
and I said I'd be happy to I see even
though it's a little bit I knew that it
must be doing some good for someone and
even though they never recognized me I
wanted to give a comment in support sure
I did
so then all of a sudden it was a shock
to find out they were Person of the Year
okay so I go to the article my comments
not there and I call her and I say why
did you want my comment if you were
going to put it in and her comment back
to me was well when they did the writers
have control over that and I guess they
just had too many others during clue
yeah yeah if we're talking about me - we
wouldn't want the woman who was actually
physically raped in there let's have
let's have a 2 was a 2 - white chick
what's named in that show - too urban
- drunk - drunk chicks I don't know that
sitcom yeah it's just so it's like now
let's get yeah when you broke yeah we'll
make some time look at Mindy Kaling in
here what do you think about this isn't
isn't Chris Hardwick a dick just
surprised I mean I understand they have
editorial control and we have to make
edits sometimes for this show we don't
have to make nearly as many edits as
typical kind of corporate network media
or Time magazine but that is very
striking to me do you remember who was
included what's the quotes at all oh no
I just went through sort of hardly
looked at my minute then look for mine
and when she said that to me I was so
hurt and I never even looked at it again
do you remember what that what your
comment was or to what effect it might
have
but I thought there were some areas
where they could possibly reach a
broader political yeah I was gonna say
that's exactly what did it if this is a
very balanced approach a balanced
comment from an actual survivor of rape
I don't think you were gonna make the
cut you weren't getting a screen test
when he was happy that the organization
was doing this but as months and months
go by they do not recognize us never
reach out to us yeah
we've tried to do support for them
that's wrong what I do have a question
for you on this because as he discussed
you know back in the 60s there was some
some victim-blaming going on where well
you made some bad decisions therefore
you deserve this but then that was
conflated with slut-shaming with not
believing any and all claims and then
that led to campus tribunals and
mattress girl in UVA and just he raped
me and it turned out to be completely
false
and they've ruined the reputation of
young men forever as a survivor of rape
and people throw this term around so
flippantly survivor of sexual assault
now something survivor of rape it's
survivor of sexual assault someone shows
a plastic pecker at a party and all of
sudden your survivor like you have a
barcode on your arm for a loss but it's
just it's really belittling the actual
survivors from painful ordeals but have
you seen that the pendulum swing would
you say too far the other way because we
certainly don't want to victim blame but
we certainly don't want to just allow
allegations of rape to go out against
anybody especially in this information
age with zero accountability at all you
know a lady put a tweet on and i
retweeted it this morning and she said
you know Schumer's put out all these
numbers to call if you've been sexually
abused and she said what number do I
call if my only son is falsely accused
of sexual misconduct
I don't I don't know if there is there a
hotline for that I don't know I thought
she could be looking for one and I
wanted to help her but I assumed there
wasn't what you say
look what's done to the man that are
yeah I think I think it's important to
note by the way that there are still
plenty of men now who do get blacklisted
do get blacklisted and rightfully so
they're still pleased when you look at
Weinstein when you look at Spacey when
you look at Cosby there still is a
process and a lot of these people get
convicted or a lot of these people have
some serious settlements out of court or
even look at all riley and was a 13
million with six different women
i mean these aren't exactly i mean
they're people on the right and on the
left this isn't something that goes
completely unaccounted for but what
would you say what should the burden of
proof be then in these instances well
what do you if a woman comes forward and
says okay i was raped by this guy let's
say it's a campus rape like mattress
girls turned out to be false or let's
say it's Kavanagh what burden of proof
do you think would be fair to be
required what Christine for does not I
just I can't imagine of course now day
and time you know just tell somebody
tell somebody you can trust as soon as
possible on the record I would imagine
yeah because it is one thing to have as
you said there are several friends in
normal Rogers is one of them but people
can do their own research for themselves
and it's another thing to not know the
location time what happened and whether
you were raped or not on the other
stroke isn't the other story with with
Kavanagh that it he might have revealed
his wiener but or it might have been a
fake wiener yeah that's a big difference
I know he's also ridiculous they thought
this was just gonna pass right through
and they were going to get rid of no
they didn't realize what a strong man
that he is and what a strong family and
what a strong supporter yes yes and just
for the record I'm pretty sure we have
fake wieners in our prop closet
somewhere around that we've had to use
so we have women who work for us please
please let's not
let's not get Gloria Allred on the phone
all right so listen I really appreciate
you taking the time to sit down with us
and I know you'll probably talking with
some other people is anything else you
want to do you want to leave us with I
know that you'd better put some ice on
that is the book Juanita Broderick calm
but any closing thoughts no so we can
stand with Brett Kavanaugh and I would
love to be able to ask Dianne Feinstein
and Chuck Schumer why they turned their
backs on me in 1999 and refused to read
my deposition with Ken Starr not one
Democrat read it well I'll tell you what
people out there who are watching this
we I don't do fine seen and Schumer have
a Twitter still we'll figure it out they
either have a Twitter or an Instagram if
not a phone number but we'll have people
in audience please do go forward and ask
them that question because I think it's
an important question considering how
quickly they've jente jumped on these
other bandwagons Juanita Broderick calm
you'd better put some ice on that as the
name of the book thank you so much for
taking the time and discussing what is
no doubt I know a painful experience but
hey helping more people from it thank
you
hey you if you liked this video I'd say
subscribe but that may not need anything
I'd say hit the notification bell but
who knows when you're watching this it
may not mean anything these videos
playing may not even be there anymore I
don't know what what year is it that
you're seeing this it's the internet it
lives forever but coming it will never
die you can join mug Club atlatl cutter
calm slash mug Club Nelly do you get the
clips we get the full late-night 45
minutes show every single day 99 dollars
for students 69 for students veteran or
active military it's the only way to
keep us going because we cannot subsist
off of YouTube alone as you see it's
there they're clamping down on us but
listen pedophiles interested in tweens
twinks I don't know theirs they're
[ __ ] they're fine they'll they will
always have a home here but we may not
my club join it help us help us fight
pedophiles